Well, hello everyone out there on Rumble
and YouTube land.
I'm only uh anticipating that you are
looking for pharmacist Ben.
However,
because I did not do my homework and
double check, I didn't recognize that
pharmacist Ben is visiting with family
this week and will not be on the show
tonight. So, it is just me, Coach AJ.
There's no pharmacist Ben.
Uh so I do apologize for sending you all
an email and uh letting you folks come
in and uh be all salivating to see
pharmacist Ben because it's just me
tonight. There is no pharmacist Ben. And
uh I just want to take a couple minutes
to say hello and thank you all for
tuning in.
Just mention a couple housekeeping
things. Uh, you know, the the topic
tonight was based on some articles that
pharmacist Ben had sent us and um just a
thought of us needing to take
responsibility for our own health as
opposed to
uh having uh others dictate what our
health outcomes are going to be uh by
using uh pharmaceuticals
when we should
um
be utilizing
uh our brains and knowing that what we
put in our m in our mouths or inject
into our arms and eventually everything
that gets into our bloodstream is what
affects our health and that is the key
to what we kind of talk about the root
not the fruit. fruit is the
manifestation
of the issue that we have. Uh but the
you know what we put in or neglect to
put in will uh determine uh our outcomes
and obviously we're not what we eat but
we are what we absorb. So we want to
make our environments um
amicable to the good things that we want
to put in. Uh so that is point number
one. Point number two, if you are a
prayerful person, be sure and send one
out for uh pharmacist Ben and uh his
family and I'm sure that he will
appreciate the sentiment and the good
vibrations.
So that is point number two and really
that's point number one. Point number
three
is we are a community of certified
holistic health coaches, health coaches
in general and folks who are advocating
uh for you to take control of your own
health journey.
And uh we are always looking for others
to join
uh what Dr. Wallak has started as a
crusade
30 uh years ago plus maybe 40 years ago.
And if you would like to be a part of
our team,
uh first and foremost, if someone
invited you to watch this show, which is
going to be very brief because there's
no pharmacist Ben. If someone invited
you, you get back with that person. If
you have a health question, be sure to
email us at questionsailywithdoc.com.
That's questions at dailywithdoc.com.
Uh if you would like to uh speak to a
certified holistic health coach,
uh feel free to reach out at the number
on the bottom of the screen,
855-9493377.
Uh be sure to do that.
Um,
and as well as I was kind of getting at
is we are looking for people who want to
help their community.
If you have an opportunity to do so,
please do so. And we just want to say
another special shout out to Becca
Dukes. This is family week where Becca
Dukes is visiting with her mom. Also, we
want to give a nice shout out to Mama
Dukes out in Washington uh for and thank
her for producing such a lovely young
lady who is helping thousands and
thousands of people have better health
journeys. And the same goes with
pharmacist Ben. uh you know this is a
guy who spends countless hours on a on a
weekly basis doing the same uh helping
others.
So the point of today is
if you would like to um ask a question
be sure to go ask that question at
questions dailywithdoc.com.
If you just would like to research on
your own and learn more about what we're
talking about, what we do, why we do it,
you can go to
dailywithdoc
team.com.
And I'll put that on a ticker here.
Dailywithdoc
team.com.
That would be a good place for you to go
to uh get some information.
uh dailywithdoc team.com
as well of course dailywithdoc.com
uh you can watch all uh different
replays uh get some products etc and of
course you see triangleofd disease.com
be sure to read the description on
whatever platform you're watching us on
and you will see the different uh uh
sites that you can get more information.
I would suggest anyone not really
familiar with what we do uh that you go
to dailywithdocct team.com.
Uh there are a lot of questions that
have come in. I apologize for uh having
you folks think that pharmacist Ben
would be here. Um he will not be around
on Friday for dealing withdoc either.
But if you do email questions at
dailywithdoc.com,
we will sure be sure to get those
questions answered for you. Um,
I guess I'm just going to wrap my
statement by letting you know that there
is a a video that I'm going to play.
It's about seven minutes and it talks
about
the whole concept of the root, not the
fruit. We are talking about you want to
go upstream. You want to go to where the
problem began. The problem didn't begin
begin with the acne that you see on your
skin. The problem did not begin with the
um
the the edema that you see your swollen
ankles and and legs. That's not where
the problem began. the problem did not
begin
uh with your headache,
but we take things and do things to
address those issues directly there
where we need to go to the root of the
problem. So, I'm going to play a small
video and then end the show that way. I
thank you all for tuning in. I do
apologize, but we will be back without
fail next Monday night at 900 p.m. Thank
you very much.
>> Hey, welcome to the explainer. This is
where we take really big, sometimes
complicated ideas and well, we break
them down into frameworks you can
actually use. So, today we're going to
unpack something really interesting.
It's pharmacist Ben Futur's whole
philosophy on why we get sick and more
importantly, his unified strategy for
health. We're going to start with a
frustration I think a lot of us share.
Then we'll travel upstream to what he
says are the real root causes. And
finally, we'll look at his big picture
solution. All right, let's dive right
in. And we're going to start with a
feeling that, well, it's something a lot
of us know all too well. It's that
feeling of being caught in a frustrating
cycle, especially if you're dealing with
a chronic health issue. You know the
drill, right? You're bouncing from one
specialist to the next just trying to
get some answers. I mean, it seems like
the logical thing to do, doesn't it?
You've got an issue with a specific part
of your body, so you go see the doctor
who specializes in exactly that part.
But here's where pharmacist Ben Fuches
throws a wrench in the works. He asks a
really critical question. What if this
superfocused approach, this this laser
focus is actually making us miss the
bigger picture entirely? So, you know,
an eye problem, off you go to the
opthalmologist. A heart issue and bam,
you're seeing a cardiologist and you
know, a skin thing pops up. So, it's a
visit to the dermatologist. And look,
each of these experts is doing their
job, right? They're diligently tackling
their one specific piece of the puzzle.
But here's the kicker. According to
Fuks, this whole fragmented approach, it
completely misses the point. He argues
that all of these separate diverse
symptoms, you know, from your kidneys to
your skin to whatever else, they aren't
separate problems at all. They're just
different branches on the same dying
tree. They're all signs of one single
systemic issue that he pretty bluntly
calls MBFA disease or my body is falling
apart disease. Okay, so if chasing down
each individual symptom isn't the
answer, then what is? Well, this is
where Fuk says we need to adopt a
totally new first principle. And this
right here, this is his core idea. He
says where you see the problem is not
where the problem begins. The symptom
you're looking at is just a signal. the
real cause that's located upstream. So
what does he actually mean by going
upstream? Well, it's pretty simple
really. It means you have to trace that
symptom, whatever it is, all the way
back to its true origin. And Fox argues
that this journey, it almost always
leads you back to the body's main
operating systems, your digestion and
your metabolism. But he's really clear
on one point, the digestive system, it's
not just another part to look at. He
says it is the root system. It's the
soil that your entire health grows out
of. Okay, so let's actually follow that
stream, right? Let's go upstream. The
first major system we hit is the blood.
And according to folks, the blood can
become well, a literal highway for
toxicity. His claim is this. All disease
is cell disease. It all starts at the
cellular level. And why do cells get
sick? Because of what the blood delivers
to them, or just as important, what it
fails to deliver. So, Fuks points a
finger at two main culprits that make
our blood dirty, as he calls it. First
up, you've got a compromised gut. You've
probably heard the term leaky gut, and
that's when stuff that's supposed to
stay in your digestive system leaks out
into your bloodstream. Not good. And the
second big one, high blood sugar. He
says sugar acts like a toxin that
literally makes your blood thick and
sludgy. And that sludgy blood is a major
driver of inflammation all over the
body. And this is where a really
dangerous chain reaction kicks off. this
toxic, sludgy blood, it just can't do
its job right. It can't deliver oxygen
and nutrients the way it's supposed to.
So what happens? Your organs start to
get starved and at the same time they're
getting poisoned. And that just leads to
this massive cascade of problems
everywhere in the body. This brings us
to a really powerful analogy he uses.
Fox calls our circulatory system the
railroad of toxicity. Just picture it.
This dirty, sludgy blood is like a train
chugging through your entire body. And
it's making stops at every single
station. The heart, the brain, the skin,
you name it. And at every single stop,
it's dropping off a little toxic
package. Okay, so we've talked about the
blood. But if we go even further
upstream, there's another absolutely
critical area, the very structure that
literally holds our body together. We're
talking about connective tissue. And
this is where he really, I mean, really
flips the script on how we think about
aging. He takes all these common
conditions and reframes them as just a
breakdown of this one thing, connective
tissue. I mean, think about this for a
second. Glaucoma. He says that's not
just an eye problem. It's osteoporosis
of the eye. Wrinkles on your skin,
that's osteoporosis of the skin. All of
a sudden, you see, it's all pointing
back to the same fundamental mechanism.
And the way he describes his connective
tissue is it's just incredible. It's not
just some boring passive scaffolding
holding you up. No, he calls it the goo
and the glue of the body. It's the jello
mold that gives your organs their shape
and holds them in place. And get this,
he even calls it the womb for every
single cell, the very matrix that
nurtures them. This all leads him to
coin this amazing and kind of funny term
for what we see as aging. He calls it
blobification. you know that sagging,
that loss of firmness and structure that
we all notice over time. He says at its
core, that's just blobification. It's
the physical sign that our vital
connective tissue is breaking down.
Okay, so if the big root problems are
dirty blood and deteriorating connective
tissue, what do we do about it? What's
the solution? Well, Fuches proposes a
unified strategy that goes right after
these root causes. So, you can forget
the old idea of a specific pill for a
specific ill. His solution is a
multi-pronged approach that's all about
restoring the body's foundation. It
means you stop chasing symptoms and you
start focusing on the real stuff. You
focus on fixing the gut to clean up the
blood at the source. You work on
controlling your blood sugar to get rid
of that toxic sludge. You use strategic
supplements to literally rebuild that
connective tissue. You improve
oxygenation, and that can be as simple
as deep breathing. And finally, you help
your entire system detoxify itself. And
this right here really captures that
fundamental shift in thinking. The
standard medical model often feels like
you're just treating the rotten fruit on
the tree. You're focused on the symptom.
This systemic model, it's about ignoring
the fruit for a second, getting down on
your hands and knees and focusing all of
your energy on nourishing the roots of
the tree. And that really is the crucial
takeaway from all this. Once you start
to understand these upstream mechanisms,
your whole role can shift. You go from
being a passive patient, you know, just
receiving treatments to becoming an
active, empowered participant in your
own health story. So ultimately, this
whole framework challenges us to ask a
new question. What if that problem
you're dealing with isn't the problem at
all? What if it's just a signal, a
message from your body inviting you to
look deeper, to go upstream, and to
finally find the true underlying cause?
Okay, folks. So, I wonder about this
next one. I want you to comment if you
think that this is accurate or not. This
is
>> You survived cancer, but the treatments
that saved your life often leave the
body in a state of extreme physical
trauma. You may find yourself dealing
with shedding tissue, exposed nerve
endings, and constant pain. Standard
pharmaceutical relief frequently fails
in these cases because the core issue is
structural. Your connective tissue
matrix, the biological womb where your
cells live, has physically dissolved.
Healing this environment is a mechanical
process. It requires rebuilding the
matrix from the ground up using specific
raw materials. By following a strict
five-step recipe, you can provide the
body with the components needed to patch
raw nerve endings and reconstruct your
cellular matrix. Step one is vitamin C.
This nutrient acts as the absolute
biological rate limiter for tissue
creation, meaning your body is
physically unable to manufacture new
connective tissue without it. In cases
of extreme postcancer tissue trauma,
standard oral doses are generally
insufficient to meet the body's repair
demands. Intravenous vitamin C allows
for much higher concentrations to reach
the matrix where it serves as a primary
anti-inflammatory and natural pain
reliever. Step two involves
polysaccharides. The matrix is a wet
environment that requires specific
biological mush.
You can source these materials from
fukcoidin z algae, aloe vera, and fresh
vegetable juices. These polysaccharides
act as sticky electromagnetic seeds.
They bind with water to create a
protective barrier that patches up raw
exposed nerve endings, combining the
rate limiting power of vitamin C with
these electromagnetic seeds creates the
foundational environment necessary to
sustain new cellular life. Step three is
the scaffolding. Your body cannot
synthesize new tissue out of thin air.
It requires heavy structural rebar to
replace what was shredded. To saturate
the system, you need specific structural
elements, collagen peptides, highquality
whey protein, and specialized gluco gel
capsules. Treat this postcancer matrix
damage with the same aggressive
structural approach used to address
severe degenerative arthritis. Step four
is stopping the leak. Providing premium
raw materials is useless if you continue
to subject the system to metabolic
stress. This illustrates the futility of
building while simultaneously
destroying. You cannot repair a house
while the foundation is being
undermined. This requires an immediate
halt to toxic inputs, specifically fried
fats, processed sugars, and the standard
American diet. Physical recovery remains
impossible if the intake of inflammatory
toxins outpaces your body's ability to
lay down new connective rebar. The fifth
and final requirement for this protocol
is neurological. The body suspends
tissue rebuilding when stuck in a
sympathetic emergency mode, blocking
nutrients from entering the matrix.
Repair only occurs when shifting into a
parasympathetic state, rest and digest.
This is the exclusive environment where
connective repair is permitted. You can
force the body into this state through
mechanical actions like deep
diaphragmatic breathing, targeted
gratitude, and prayer. Regulating your
thoughts gives the biological machinery
the necessary permission to divert
energy away from defense and toward
healing. Without this neurological
signal, even a perfect diet and
supplement protocol will remain dormant
and unused by yourselves. The matrix
reconstruction protocol is complete.
These five pillars, vitamin C,
polysaccharides, structural proteins,
toxin removal, and a regulated nervous
system, rebuild the body. The human body
is a regenerating machine designed to
renew itself continually. Healing is
your body's default nature. The moment
it is provided with the correct raw
materials and relieved of metabolic
stress, you can move past the fear of
your symptoms. By beginning the
mechanical reconstruction protocol
today, you can take back control of your
internal matrix.
>> Okay. To me, that one was pretty
powerful. I need you to comment on what
your thoughts on that were. And then the
last uh I'm going to show you is talking
about absorption because you're not what
you eat, you are what you absorb.
>> In this generated video, a single red
blood cell deflates and loses its color
in a dark void. This is the visual
reality of anemia, a condition where the
blood lacks the healthy cells needed to
transport oxygen. Every day, millions
dutifully swallow iron supplements to
combat this. yet their blood work
remains unchanged. We often blame the
supplement's quality or the brand's
strength, but the true flaw lies within
the body's internal delivery system.
Swallowing a mineral is merely the first
step. It does not guarantee your body
will actually absorb it. If the
physiological pipeline is blocked, the
raw material is useless. Resolving
chronic anemia requires a structural
mission to unblock three specific
anatomical bottlenecks. a goal that
remains out of reach by simply
increasing the daily dosage. The journey
begins at the stomach, the first
critical barrier. To break down raw
iron, the stomach must maintain an
intensely corrosive environment with a
pH level between 1 and 2. PH is a scale
used to specify the acidity or basicity
of an aquous solution. Manufacturing
this hydrochloric battery acid requires
a steady supply of chloride, the
essential raw material the body uses to
fuel digestion. This historic photograph
shows workers mining raw salt deep
underground. Historically, the body
relied on sodium chloride to produce
digestive acids. However, modern
medically recommended low salt diets can
inadvertently starve the stomach of this
critical building block. Without
adequate chloride, acid production
drops. The iron capsule remains intact,
passing through the stomach without ever
being dissolved or utilized.
Supplementing iron while simultaneously
restricting salt creates a biochemical
stalemate. The body lacks the tools to
process the very nutrients it needs. If
the iron manages to dissolve, it reaches
the small intestine. This is the primary
site where minerals cross the final
barrier into the bloodstream. This
microscopic image shows healthy
intestinal villi. These are tiny
finger-like structures that act like an
absorbent shag rug, maximizing the
surface area available to capture
nutrients. This historic photograph
captures workers threshing wheat in the
field. Modern wheat, barley, rye, and
oats all contain gluten, a protein that
can act as a contact toxin for sensitive
intestinal tissues. Upon contact with
gluten, these delicate villi swell up,
suffocating their internal blood supply.
Eventually, they die off, leaving behind
restrictive scar tissue. This animated
diagram illustrates the physical damage.
The complex folded surface on the left
flattens into the smooth line on the
right, causing the absorptive surface
area to plummet by 98%. The intestine
transforms into a non-absorbent plastic
tube. Once the gut becomes a smooth
tube, systemic malnutrition is
inevitable. At this stage, no amount of
oral iron can penetrate the scarred
barrier. This microscopic image shows
the bone marrow matrix located deep
within the skeletal system. This is the
final destination for successfully
absorbed iron. By focusing on the dense
clusters of purple stained cells, we can
see the body's active manufacturing
zones. The marrow is a high-speed
factory and iron is only one of the
materials required to build a red blood
cell. To keep the assembly line moving,
the body requires co-actors, helper
nutrients like copper, zinc, and vitamin
B12. These work alongside the
foundational 90 essential nutrients to
complete the synthesis of blood. If the
factory lacks structural materials like
collagen or is missing one minor
co-actor, production halts. The
machinery remains idle despite the
presence of iron. Chronic anemia is
frequently the signal of a total factory
failure in the marrow caused by these
missing co-actors rather than a simple
iron deficit. Clearing these bottlenecks
requires a road map to repair the
anatomy and restore the body's natural
production. Step one is the immediate
elimination of all dietary gluten. This
stops the ongoing scarring and allows
the delicate intestinal nlli to slowly
regrow their vital absorptive texture.
Step two focuses on the stomach.
Reintroducing salt to taste and using
digestive enzyme supplements helps
restore the corrosive environment needed
to dissolve minerals effectively. Next,
flood the system with the 90 essential
nutrients, specifically copper,
alongside collagen and MSM. MSM is a
naturally occurring sulfur compound the
body uses to provide structural
scaffolding for tissues. Step 5 utilizes
highly bioavailable liquid mineral
supplements. These bypass many digestive
hurdles to ensure the factory in the
bone marrow finally receives its missing
components. Chronic anemia is a
mechanical failure, not a permanent
genetic sentence. By finally unblocking
the supply chain, you give your body the
exact tools it needs to rebuild itself.
>> You give your body the exact tools it
needs.
And whether
or not you agree,
this is what we're talking about,
you know, we talked uh about looking at
the root cause of an issue. We talked
about the environment of the blood and
then we talked about how to absorb
nutrients
uh through the digestive system. If the
digestive system is not um
readily available to accept nutrients,
you're not going to do so. And we also
talked about how to rebuild the body.
So, what we want to do
is if you've got questions and thanks
Harry, thanks Becca for being here.
Harry's all the way down under and
tuning in. It's probably mourning for
him now. Uh but um so we're looking into
the future. Harry's message is coming to
us from the future. Uh so if you uh are
able
uh to help others or have a desire to
help others, we can teach you how to be
a health coach.
If you are looking for help, reach out
to us either way. We'd love to hear from
you. So, please email us at
questions@dailywithdoc.com.
questionsailywithdoc.com.
Tell us what you thought. Tell us what
you think. Tell us what you're looking
for. Tell us how we can help you. And
tell us if you'd like to help others.
That's what we're here to do.
Got to spread the word. You got to help
people
take their power back and not remain a
human guinea pig. And that is my spiel
and I will see you all next time.
for you.
Hey